ok il fait passer auprès des gosses à
prague raw fusion hp dit qu'ils postent
gratter pour que j'apporte des cadeaux à
ses enfants noël salut vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce
[Musique]
c'est l'heure de se réveiller et razel
réveille toi
t'as rien
[Musique]
j'ai faut
lutter
contre nous les infos
la police
[Musique]
fait peur
c'est toi et maa je me fais un petit
bisou moi où tu piques aux fables ou
tard est ce que vous voulez me chanter
une petite chanson
n'est pas pour
gagner
[Musique]
frère jacques
dormir ou
louent tous les jouets les jouer quand y
aller
[Musique]
rigueur encore fait des dons nous
c'est tout à fait finie apprécié
allez c'est fini c'est noël au revoir
on voit les gens chantent
[Musique]